Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles has been
around since the 80s but the minds
behind mutant Mayhem may have figured
out a way to give us a fresh perspective
on the characters we know and love the
concept behind the animation is like
nothing you've ever heard of the cast is
full of some of the biggest names in
Hollywood and they pretty much threw the
script away and let the actors take the
Reigns one of the most important things
about this movie something that hasn't
actually been done in the history of
this franchise and more on that later
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
actually looked and sounded like
teenagers it's nice right this simple
concept brought up another idea for the
producers what if it's animated by teen
now what does that mean exactly the
concept behind this was taking sort of
doodle drawings that would have been
done on the side of a notebook and
turning that into an entire movie weird
shapes and praising perspective you
would reach this point where you're like
little bit Morris Q they kept using the
words teenage energy when it came to
creating the look and feel for the movie
so this is surprisingly the first time
in the history of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle franchise that the turtles
were voiced by real teenagers okay to be
fair a couple of them did technically
reach adulthood by the time the movie
was finished but throughout the
recording process all of them were in
their teens another cool thing about
this is none of the adults in the room
gave them any input on how to act like
teens they'd be like what did you just
say Riz use that in the movie explain it
to me and then let's use all the guys
ended up getting super close because of
all the freedom they had in their
recording booths to riff off each other
and just be themselves they also were
encouraged to improv a ton of the movie
but more on that later so how
unconventional was the recording process
of this movie in every animated movie
Seth Rogen was ever in he never even met
the cast until the day of the premiere
he didn't want this movie to be made
that way so they always made sure every
Ninja Turtle voice actor was in the same
room and often encouraged them to talk
over one another I think they don't do
it just because it's way harder it's way
harder to schedule having everyone there
at the same time it's also technically a
lot harder to record everything with
that many people they would have some
sessions where seven or eight people all
recorded at the same time that's
definitely not a normal thing when it
comes to creating animated films so back
to the fact that a lot of this movie was
improv when they first started recording
Seth Rogen wasn't super impressed by the
scenes where everyone was essentially
just reciting their lines as they were
written in the script he couldn't really
put his finger on what it was but it
just felt really rigid it wasn't until
he overheard the boys hanging out in the
sound booth together and just hanging
out eating snacks that he got his big
idea we should throw out the script and
just tell them what the scene is and
have them all just like screaming each
other it kind of turned into a natural
flow of the movie even when they would
bring other characters in they just sort
of Riff Off each other apparently Seth
Rogen would just throw out a topic for
them to argue and banter about along
with the rundown of what the scene was
and then everyone would just wing it
you've gotta have a majorly talented
cast to trust everyone enough to
essentially Just Wing the movie there
are some huge names attached obviously
we've got Seth Rogen and Jackie Chan
behind the voices of Bebop and Splinter
don't use that word that way but
Nicholas Cantu Shimon Brown Jr Micah
Abbey and Brady noon are all newcomers
onto the scene of animation with only a
few screen credits but they fell into
their roles of the Ninja Turtles quite
naturally we also get the pleasure of
hearing AO atabiri who is most notably
known for her roles in big mouth and the
bear as the voice of April O'Neil so you
were baby turtles who made contact with
mystery goo other big names include post
Malone
Hannibal Burris Ice Cube and Rose Byrne
the soundtrack is actually one of the
most exciting aspects of this film Seth
Rogen Compares it to the soundtrack
that's in the Tony Hawk Pro Skater video
game from 1999. if you know you know the
iconic Duo Trent razor and Atticus Ross
from Nine Inch Nails teamed up to score
the movie they previously worked on the
score for the Social Network together
which won an Academy Award for best
original score and the girl with a
dragon tattoo which won a Grammy for
Best score soundtrack for visual media
they also collaborated with John Batiste
on Pixar's Soul which walked away with
both an Academy Award and a Golden Globe
for its soundtrack so yeah the bar is
set pretty high for Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Mutant mayhem's score Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles is one of the most
successful longest running franchises
ever made but this mutant Mayhem gives
our beloved characters a majorly fresh
twist with Jackie Chan Seth Rogen and
other major players behind the screen an
epic soundtrack by award-winning
musicians and the chaotically hilarious
improv of four teenage boys what else do
you really need what's your favorite
behind the scenes fact